cette église a failli disparaître
en 2003 elle a été touchée par la
canicule et menaçait de s'effondrer par
l'église s'était fissurée mais des
fissures comme ça ici ici la décision a
été prise de sauvegarder le bâtiment
plutôt que de le détruire pour la
municipalité la recherche de financement
a été un parcours du combattant
elle a apporté 40 % du prix des travaux
en plus des aides publiques
c'est très lourd financièrement on nous
sommes une commune de 510 520 habitants
voilà en fonction du budget ce qui nous
arrivait était une catastrophe
et cette église les habitants ils sont
attachés les églises ça compte dans les
communes quoi cette clocher du village
c'est oui
la sonnerie des cloches les gens j'ai lu
ce tout ça on aime bien les églises sont
des bâtiments incontournable du paysage
français
mais elle sent très cher à entretenir
dans ce lieu-dit l'église n'est plus
utilisée pour le culte depuis 2013 et
elle aurait pu être vendus aux plus
offrants par la mairie pourtant des
habitants se sont battus pour la
conserver toujours l'idée d'enlever
l'hôtel quoi parce que c'est quand même
encombrant impensable pour eux de
laisser leur patrimoine disparaître vous
savez l'église dans un village c'est
quelque chose d'important
les gens ils tiennent c'est notre seul
patrimoine nanou si vous voulez tout le
monde a quelque chose ou étaient
baptisés ou a fait sa communion use et
mariella c'est important l'association
souhaite transformer l'église en centre
culturel pour accueillir des expositions
il reste maintenant à trouver les moyens
financiers
d'autres églises abandonnées depuis 150
ans retrouve un autre lustres dans un
domaine plus commercial ce viticulteur
prévoit de transformer le bâtiment en
cave à vin les ouvriers sont déjà à pied
d'oeuvre pour la transformation
le propriétaire a préféré rénové pour
conserver le patrimoine mais aussi par
amour des vieilles pierres
c'est plus cher effectivement que de
refaire une construction neuve mais on
n'a pas le même charme
c'est vraiment un lieu que tout le monde
voit tous les jours que les passants les
habitants les touristes voix et notre
souhait c'était vraiment de réhabiliter
cette ancienne église qui était vraiment
un bâtiment qui partait vraiment à
l'abandon
cave centre culturel les églises peuvent
avoir une nouvelle vie à une époque où
les fonds publics se font de plus en
plus rare que beaucoup d'églises ne
peuvent pas bénéficier dette de fonds
patrimoniaux et que les cultes sont
moins nombreux il faut bien trouver des
solutions pour éviter la disparition
d'un patrimoine si cher aux habitants